tonight a historian at the mob museum is
weighing in on the discovery of the body
found in a barrel at lake mead joe
moeller spoke with a historian at the
museum who says he has a lot of
questions
it certainly is of interest to us at the
mom museum we would love to
know more about this it's a mystery that
has caught the attention of not only the
nation but world a body found in a
barrel police believe the victim was
shot in the 70s or 80s this probably is
not the last body in a barrel that we're
going to see in las vegas with las vegas
mob mob-related past historian jeff
schumacher from the mob museum has a lot
of questions killing somebody and
putting him in a barrel and dumping him
in water is actually a common mob tactic
going back to the 1800s he says bodies
of many mobsters were killed in the same
way throughout history it may not be a
mob hit it may be somebody who sort of
copied the tactics of the mob but when
we're talking about the era 1970s 1980s
the mob was pretty prominent in las
vegas at that time and it was a time of
a lot of conflicts as well so there were
people who went missing he says
regardless of who committed the crime
the circumstances around the case could
provide answers for a decades-old
mystery i'm going to be watching this
very closely i think we're going to try
to you know obtain the medical reports
and try to learn as much as we can about
it and see if we can be helpful to
authorities to you know see if we can
solve this crime